[موسيقى]
3000 كيلومتر من السواحل الممتده على طول
ثلاثه بحار كانت كفيله بخلق ارتباط تاريخي
وثيق مع العمانيين
[موسيقى]
اليوم ما وصلت الينا في الفئه البحريه
تعني شيء الكثير
[موسيقى]
استعراض الشبان القادمين من ريفي وجبال
ظفار موروثاتهم الراقصه يطهر التناغم مع
طبيعه الحياه الجبليه
[موسيقى]
الزامل او الهبوط
وعندكرارت
بحكم طبيعتها وبيئتها وبعض الفنون الذي
يتعامل معاهم مع الاساسي
يمتد على مئات الكيلومترات وعلى ازمنه
متعاقبه
ويحتضن مدن حضريه عريقه اسهمت في تشكل
الوان فكريه وثقافيه متعدده
التجول في قريه عوده الماضي التراثيه يمثل
رحله تفاعليه لزوار موسم الخريف لاستكشاف
تاريخ محافظه ظفار فالمحافظه الزاخره
بتنوعها الجغرافي ثريه بالفنون والتراث
والعادات الاصيله
يفخر مسلم الكثير بمنطقته البدويه في ظفار
التي تنبت فيها شجره اللبان الشهيره
[موسيقى]
الذي جاء مع خمسين من ابناء قبيلته لتكسيد
ثقافه البدو يرى ان قوافل اجداده القدامى
قهرت صحراء الربع الخالي
البدويه معتمدين على الله ثم على الابل
اللبن هي اللي تشلهم زادهم ولا تشلهم
اهلهم يروحون فوقها كان حج وان كان سفارات
وان كان ينقلون فوق هالبضائع وبينما كان
رجال طفار يجوبون البحار والصحاري كانت
نساؤهم يصنعن في منازلهن البهجه
ويوقدن نار الشوق في انتظار عودتهم
جنوبيه سلطنه عمان